this is thiago pivavarcik and jeff
taylor
of new york art forensics and this is a
jackson pollock
or at least it looks like one but it's
actually a fake
here's how they figured it out today we
will perform all the steps necessary
to determine its authorship
[Music]
jackson pollock was an american painter
that
painted from the early 20s to the 1950s
he's best known by the drift or court
paintings
that he did from 1947
to the time of his death in 1956.
pollock's grip paintings are considered
his best period
so uh good sized well-preserved
jackson pollock he can go for over 100
million dollars
there's a lot of claims of jackson
pollock drip paintings
and our laboratory was able to identify
over a hundred fakes so we can say that
we found more fakes and there are
authentic jackson pollocks over there
[Music]
we received this painting by a client
that
chose to remain anonymous we're going to
call him sydney
first step when we receive a painting
we're trying to establish something
called the provenance
provenance is a chain of ownership and
custody of an artwork
from the contemporary ownership
all the way back to its manufacturing
where this painting came from what is
the story behind it
is there anything that shows the history
of this artwork
so this is one of the most fascinating
documents that i've ever seen
this is a document to explain why sydney
should have a jackson pollock
most bargeries there are not as much
forgeries
of confidence with forgeries or
documentation
this is problematic in all these
different ways the facts has no number
dr armand hirschkovitz cannot be
referenced
there's no record of a tear gallery in
dover new jersey
then he says he acquired this painting
in 1955
after pollock died but he didn't die
until 1956.
so for all these reasons this is an
incredibly unreliable
and deceitful document
the next step will be we try to find a
match
for the artwork jackson polo paintings
are specifically hard to look for
matches because
the nature of the image most of the
sources are
imprinted material and the catalog
resonate which is
the comprehensive catalogue of works
for a given artist this painting has no
match
the next step is a close-up visual
analysis
[Music]
so we're looking close to the painting
to try to find anachronistic materials
and techniques
something that would be uncharacteristic
from a given outer
or a given time it's a very very thin
layer
yeah look at how many how many colors i
count that aren't in the drip layers
it's very hard to prove there's
something
is but it's easier to find
things that are out of place things that
should not be there
look at these underlying colors we got a
yellow a green
and neither of them appear in the drip
patterns that's done with a brush
[Music]
yeah it's rather strange because when
pollock starts doing the port painting
he really doesn't
brush much anymore yep so there's no
signature here
a lot of the works going into the market
in very controversial ways
are not signed and we suspect that
someone is trying to
mitigate whatever legal repercussions
trying to
imply that unsigned work is not
forgery per se as i say it's a next
level to take the step to sign
artwork
[Music]
now you see here tiago i got two holes
right here they're just that distance
and they're repetitive you have a series
of
smaller holes and that indicates that
this canvas was a certain point staple
and staple canvases will not be a thing
on 1956. there's something
did you see the dirt here yeah that's
not nasty
it's being aged through a series of
processes
to look older it's like they spilled
something on this
through carelessness or not through
carelessness
you can see by the marks on the back how
it was
dabbed with a tea bag and if you
actually
come really close and smell it you can
smell
tea still the surface is being
sprayed with nicotine to emulate
ages of exposure to smoking but
the canvas is actually really good state
of conservation
it hasn't really shredded the way a
canvas starts to unravel at its edges
over time there's like some punctual
damage that is here
yeah you should be like all over like
this
[Music]
then the next step will be photography
so we want to see if there's any under
drawings or sketches under the paint
you never know sometimes the canvas was
reused
[Music]
do you see that that squared green there
oh yes
in this case instead of finding under
drawing actually we found
that this canvas was reused from
a prior picture that had
very regular geometric shape which is
very young characteristic from pollock
as well now we get out the uv
light if you're going to analyze the
material
aspects of the artwork we want to be
sure
that we're looking at relevant parts of
it
so we examine it with ultraviolet light
to try to look at the original parts of
the painting
normally all the restorations would show
up but
none of the restorations show up any
just different as if
the thing was done all at the same time
see look
here this cut there is a big patch
on the back and this ripping is
held together by a patch and it's gluing
it together
you see there's two little canvas
threads
are actually loose and the restoration
was made in a completely
substandard way and it doesn't seem to
be
fulfilling the purpose of a proper
conservation
the x-ray fluorescence spectrometer
that's the next step
this handy device that looks kind of
like a star trek phaser is
a really outstanding tool in the field
of art forensics i'm actually emitting
a small amount of x-rays onto the
surface of the painting
it's exciting the electrons in the
pigments there and that allows this to
identify
what elements are present it shows that
we have
titanium on it which is natural from
titanium dioxide
white pigment it's a very common
material from the 1930s for a lot of our
cases
titanium is the determining factor and
it has tripped up more forgers than any
other element
so if this were purporting to be a
painting by degas
and we found the titanium immediately we
would know no way
in this case however by the time pollock
is working titanium is a widely
available white
so to find it in pollock's work is not
surprising in fact it's well documented
that his works do contain titanium
titanium white was already available in
the 1950s
from that we move on to microscopy
so thiago is going to be taking tiny
non-destructive fragmentary samples
of different bits of paint
this process is mostly used for
organic materials with those we would
then be able to test both
the pigment and the binder we're looking
for
what is the kind of paint used
we try to take a few samples from each
color and then we use
the rama spectrometer we put in a
microscope slide
and we shine a laser over it and then
this laser bounces back
inside the machine in a slightly
different color from the original hollow
glazing
that can tell us an idea of what we're
looking at
and we found mostly acrylics
although the binder known as acrylics
did
exist at the time pollock was alive in
this one
the specific variant of acrylic did not
exist it only started being manufactured
in the 1960s
for more than 100 years scientists have
just been looking at tiny fragments
of paintings under microscopes and this
allows us to really make a visual
identification based in metals and
tiny fragments of mineralogy
so there are studies regarding jackson
pollock paintings that describe
the type of debris found in his
paintings
look at that either somebody dropped us
in a mud puddle or they
directly applied this stuff and there is
a specific type of
sedimentary rock and dust that he would
spread on his
work i think it's a piece of insulation
that's what i'm saying i don't you can't
even tell what that is but
on this case we analyzed the debris and
dust
embedded on the painting and it seems to
be
the breeze from drywall which is
inconsistent with
other pollux works
conclusion a jackson polygon that
technique
per se that is not much of a mystery so
it is our opinion
that this would not qualify as a jackson
pollock painting
as i say if the deal is too good
there's something wrong